à peine ouverte la boutique de la
distillerie est prise d'assaut par les
premiers touristes ils viennent visiter
l'usiné certes mais surtout acheter du
rhum ici à clément deux cent mille
visiteurs franchissent chaque année la
porte on a fait des années qu'ils
correspondent de l'année de naissance
des petits enfants des cubis pour offrir
et des préparations pour offrir aussi
donc on espère trouver les produits ici
locaux war amenèrent métropole ce qu'il
faut pour faire un mais planteurs les
plus proches et toutes les boissons
locales
les distilleries ont le vent en poupe le
spiri tourisme explose
l'an dernier 4 millions de litres de roy
m'ont été vendus en martinique dans deux
millions sont partis dans les valises
des touristes on peut considérer
aujourd'hui que le spectacle en
martinique sur 2018 a représenté 800
mille visiteurs qui chacun ont défoncé
entre-temps 30 et 40 euros
dans chacune leur chacune de leurs
visites dans les silos donc ont
effectivement sur un sur un chiffre
d'affaires qui est de l'ordre de plus de
30 millions d'euros générés par le
soleil tourisme en afrique
quand ensuite on a une approche
effectivement 2e de ddd des touristes
qui vont aussi en magasin on se rend
compte à ce moment là que vraiment le
chiffre d'affaires de ce pôle tourisme
dépasse largement les 100 millions
d'euros à la distillerie la favorite 314
milles litres de rhum ont été produits
c'est une petite structure familiale qui
a reçu 25 mille visiteurs l'an dernier
ici le tourisme a une importance
considérable
la vente directe sur place représente à
peu près 10% de notre chiffre d'affaires
ce qui n'est pas rien et et c'est
vraiment un contact privilégié qu'on va
pouvoir avoir avec les consommateurs
finaux qu'ils soient de martinique où
d'ailleurs principalement de métropole
est un peu d'étrangers mais peu importe
d'où ils viennent on va pouvoir leur
expliquer en direct et en toute
convivialité notre histoire notre
production et les sensibiliser
immédiatement
de la martinique le spiritualisme
implique aussi que les producteurs
investissent pour rendre leur usine
attractives comme par exemple la money
qui a injecté un peu plus d'un million
dur dans sa structure nous avons investi
dans son petit frère qui nous a augmenté
notre le nombre de visiteurs de 50% ce
qui n'est pas négligeable et nous avons
investit aussi dans le cadre dans les
boutiques dans la rénovation des
boutiques etc
si la marge de progression du tourisme
dans la filière est énorme
des efforts restent encore à faire pour
que la martinique devienne une terre de
rome la seule à disposer de
l'appellation d'origine contrôlée